NASA reports that it had a record 18,000
applicants to be astronauts Wow
18,000 18,000 that's incredible yeah
apparently apparently 1,000 more apply
every time president Trump tweets it
just keeps going up there's people that
want yeah interesting story I think this
is a positive story a Muslim model has
become the first woman to appear in a
hijab on the cover of Allure magazine
yeah yeah she she also appears in a
fashion spread entitled ten hot looks
for when you're detained at the airport
[Applause]
I'm saying progress is not a straight
line that's all I'm saying
goodwill you know the organization
goodwill yeah goodwill has returned
almost a hundred thousand dollars in
cash that was mistakenly donated to them
in a black duffel bag they returned it
yeah
spokesman for goodwill said we're not
very bright
new survey just came out it revealed
that the average time a heterosexual
couple has sex is 19 minutes 19 minutes
yeah now in my case that's 2 minutes for
sex and 17 minutes for apologizing
I have graphs explaining where I went
wrong
[Laughter]
too much too soon
you